I've recently been thinking about why we
use update children instead of lots of
set value instructions.
I'm guessing it has something
to do with data consistency.
>> Frank said he was just talking with
somebody else about consistency issues.
want to see if I can find him?
>> Yes, but I've got a doctor's
appointment to check out the medical
side effects of truth-seeing amulet's.
Hm.
The developer's free, though.
>> Yeah, you should come over.
>> want to take the company sailboat?
[MUSIC]
>> Hello and welcome.
I'm here with Puff,
an engineer on the Firebase team, and
we're here to talk about how to
keep data consistent in Firebase.
>> Yeah that's going to be fun.
>> So, Puff,
I get how you do initial design.
But how do you ensure that your data
can remain scalable afterwards?
>> Yeah, that's a good question,
it's always, always tricky, right.
When we do the initial data design,
lots of software engineers
are database modelers by education.
So we try to minimize
the duplication of data.
We go through all our
database normalization forms.
And then we notice things
don't scale up very well, and
we need to start denormalizing a bit.
So in Firebase, that pretty much comes
in the form of duplicating data.
So instead of having one place
where you store the bit of data,
you actually store it in every
place where you might need it.
So if you have a chat application, for
example, you have a list of messages and
a list of users, and
every message belongs to one user.
So it's very,
very natural to want to just store
the ID of the user and look the user up.
But that means that every time
you need to display a message,
you need to look up the user
that the message belongs to.
And it might be easier to actually store
the minimal information you need to
display for a user, like the user name,
next to every chat message.
Because then if you want to
show a list of chat messages,
you just load the messages and
you don't need to do a lookup yet.
So that's a very common thing we see,
and this is data duplication.
It's not very natural, but it's how
you can keep your data scalable.
>> Puff, would you explain what atomic
updates are versus the opposite sort of
method?
>> Yeah, sure.
So the scenario we just had
where you have a chat room and
you have the users separately, but
you keep the name of every user
with the message that they post.
And let's say that the user wants
to change their name, right.
So the first thing you need to do is
that you update the user name in their
user profile, but then you need to
loop through all chat messages and
update the names there.
So the simple way of doing this is
actually write your first update or
set value on the user profile, and
then you find all the messages that they
have, and you loop through them and
update them one by one.
That works great.
The problem with it is that if somewhere
in the middle, the user closes
the Android app, then you have, yeah,
there will be no more updates being
sent, and you have half of the messages
updated and the other half won't be.
And that's what atomic updates solve.
So with atomic updates, we build the
entire, both the changing of the name,
and the fanning that data
out into every chat message,
we put that in a single command
to the Firebase database.
So that command can be pretty big, but
it's either going to completely succeed
or it's not going to happen at all, so.
And this is very beneficial if
you're updating duplicated data.
>> So
what are the major ways that people keep
data denormalized in
the world of Firebase?
>> It's mostly about duplicating data.
So I often tell people to model
screens in their Firebase.
So the information that you need in
a screen, try to get that into one
location or as few locations
as possible in the database.
And so that's what we had before
with the chat application,
right, where you store the user
name with each message even though
you will also have their
name in the profile.
And you will see this quite often.
So we see people, if you're having
a list of bank transactions, for
example, you might want to duplicate
the credit card information for
every bank transaction.
So this is one where we
see it quite often too.
And essentially, they're all variations
on the same theme, where you duplicate
the data into multiple places so that
you only have to read fewer locations.
>> So, Puff, are there any times
when you can't use atomic updates?
>> Yeah, there are, so
atomic updates, right,
the update either makes it to
the Firebase database or it doesn't.
So there's no inconsistent
state that you can have.
We have one other way of doing that,
that's when you use a transaction.
And atomic updates and transactions,
they are sort of similar,
although they're
completely different APIs.
Why you would want to use a transaction
is if you also want to get the previous
value in there.
An atomic update can write
to multiple locations, but
you don't know the current
value on any of the locations.
If you need to know the current value,
for example if you are going to increase
a counter or keep the balance
of an account, then you need to
still use a transaction,
you can't use atomic updates.
>> So I just want to make
sure on this one, Puff, and
just make sure our developer
really understands this one.
Are there any other limits to atomic
updates that we should know about?
>> Not atomic updates per se.
One of the things, I think in the
course, we focused a lot on using atomic
updates from the Android client,
and they work great there.
But as you are updating more data,
your update command,
the network traffic will get bigger.
So there's a certain limit where it's
not a good idea to do this from a client
anymore.
If you're building a social media app,
then,
if a user on your app has a million
followers, then probably you don't want
to write all that duplicate
data from an Android device,
because it just becomes too
much data that you're sending.
So in that case you most likely want to
do still use the atomic updates, but
you want to use them from a server.
It's still the same mechanism,
you still use the same API, but
you're moving it off of the client
device to an environment where you have
probably better network connectivity,
and more memory available.
>> That makes sense.
So, Puff, thanks very much for time.
I really appreciate your help.
>> Sure.
You're welcome.
>> I think it's going to
really help our developer out.
>> Cool, that's why we're here.
>> All right, thanks a lot.
>> Sure.
>> All right, cheers.
>> Now let's hit the pool.
>> Okay.